- Hey, it's Mark Wiens here
today in Bangkok, Thailand.
I'm going to be making a Thai
street food recipe today,
pad kra pao gai khai daw.
And that is holy basil with chicken
and a fried egg on the side
all over a bed of hot rice.
It's a delicious, awesome Thai dish.
Stay tuned,
I'm going to share the
recipe with you right now.
(melodious instrumental music)
We're going to fry the eggs first
so they're all ready to go.
Put my pan over.
Thai eggs are actually
not just fried eggs,
but they're deep fried eggs.
So you do use quite a bit of oil.
You want to make sure the oil is very hot
before you put in the egg.
Actually you don't want to flip the egg.
So what you want to do is
just grab some of the oil,
and keep like putting it over the egg.
Oh yeah, that is a nice Thai style
deep fried egg right there.
You want to set the egg aside.
We're going to be using one
chicken breast for this recipe.
Alright, the first thing you want to do
is take your chicken and slice it
into nice bite size pieces.
Chicken aside, we're now going to cut up
the chilis and garlic.
And I'm going to put, I think
about, how about four chilis,
but of course, you can use as many chilis,
or as little as you like.
The normal Thai chilis.
Garlic, again you can use as
many or as little as you like,
but I am again a garlic fanatic.
I think we're going to
go with four cloves.
Now I think the easiest way to cut garlic
is to first slice off both
of the ends of the clove,
and then give it a quick smash
with the side of your knife.
And that way you can see the garlic just,
the skin just peels right off.
You don't need to get it too fine.
You just want to kind of bring out
those oils of the garlic and chilis.
So that should just about
be good right there.
Final preparation, gonna
take the holy basil leaves
off the stock.
And you just kind of pluck the leaf,
get a good bunch of holy basil,
because that is the awesome
flavor of this entire dish.
Alright.
This time make sure
it's a really high heat,
and pour in about one
tablespoon or so of oil.
Swirl that oil around
for just a few seconds.
Once it's really hot, you can
toss in the garlic and chilis.
Stir fry that for just a few seconds,
and then you can toss in your chicken.
And you want to stir fry
that chicken continuously
for about a minute or so,
and then you can add the light soy sauce,
spoon of oyster sauce, tiny bit of sugar,
and lastly a squirt of dark soy sauce.
And if it gets a little bit dry
you can add a little
bit of water in there.
Final step.
(coughs)
I like a big handful of holy basil.
As soon as you add that basil
you want to turn off the heat,
but keep stirring.
This is extremely important,
because you don't want
to overcook that basil,
which would make it lose its flavor.
Put that right over the rice,
and then that egg that we fried before.
Lay that right.
The only reason I cook
is of course to eat,
so it's hot and fresh.
Oh.
That's delicious.
It's spicy and garlicky,
and you've got that
awesome peppery sensation
from the holy basil.
I overcooked it a little
bit unfortunately,
but that's alright.
I like it a little bit runnier.
And another bite.
That extra creaminess from the egg yolk.
Yeah.
That's where it's at right there.
That is...
Alright, thank you so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed this quick recipe.
And be sure to leave comment below,
and also give it a quick thumbs up.
And happy cooking.
(melodious instrumental music)